it sounds very bad how serious is it and
how worried should we as users be it's
very difficult to know at this point
without having examined the data set
that hasn't been made public of course
and I think that will probably learn a
lot more in the course of the next few
days as more details are revealed but
it's certainly on a much larger scale
than previous breaches that we've seen
well it's a little scary you know we
know major websites were affected but
we're not going to tell you which
websites why not you know how do I know
if I need to be worried and that's one
of the really interesting questions
because you look at some of the previous
breaches and they've typically affected
a small number of websites or a single
website so in the case of the ebay
breach where you had 145 million
credentials that were leaked do we what
what does the distribution look like in
this particular case is it one company
that accounts for the vast majority of
the credentials or is it a very large
number of companies we don't know yet
Arthur you know in the case of Eva which
you cited I'm glad you did they had
enormous expenses in the last quarter
because of this briefs and what they had
to do to fight this does this are there
specific companies that are going to
know what was happening and have to face
so similar costs in the current period
in the current quarter where they're
going to suddenly start spending a lot
more to fix the problem because they
know they've got it even if we don't
know they've got it well certainly if
they've discovered that they're affected
by this breach then they're going to
have significant costs to figure out
what went wrong and what they can do
about it but one of the really scary
things about it is that there may not be
anything that they can do about it
depending on the method of attack which
is used to be able to create the breach
so some of the details that hold
security have released so far indicate
to that the hacking group started off by
just purchasing credentials online from
other hacking groups through the black
market but then they switch to using
botnet based attacks so when you use a
botnet based attack what you can do is
leverage the previous credentials you've
stolen to be able to go right through
the front door of other websites to be
able to test those credentials and
discover which ones are valid on other
websites those perverts so in other
words they learn some what they learn an
individual's username password then they
blast the same using the password across
the internet to find other places where
that user has used the same thing and
the company doesn't have
they've actually got to exposure exactly
and that's not something that
constitutes a typical security breach on
the company's part because they don't
have any vulnerability in their
infrastructure that the attackers are
exploiting they're just going right
through the log in form so how do the
company's know well they can find
evidence of those usernames and
passwords being used so in the case of
this particular attack one of the things
that they found was that the initial use
cases have been to be able to send spam
and malicious email links so the
companies that have users that are
breached they may discover these spam
links or malicious email links going out
now they report they're saying is a
Russian gang essentially who are these
people what are they doing with this
information are they selling this
information is that the endgame well
it's a very sophisticated ecosystem when
it comes to dealing in credentials so
there are many different things that
they can do it looks like so far they're
monetizing it by providing services like
sending out these malicious links in
some cases what they can do is they can
use the botnets that they have built in
order to be able to create even more
sophisticated attacks attacks like man
in the browser which can be used to take
those credentials and then steal money
from people's bank accounts but the
level of monetization that they can
actually accomplish is based on the
specific type of attack that they're
selling to the rest of the black market
one of the ìiî imagine this affects so
many different businesses that would you
know ten years ago the companies would
have faced this kind of thing had
nascent businesses online but morn was
more more companies turn to sort of
being online being a mobile even I
wonder what their the company's risks
are and how they
mediate that with their insurance or
whatever else well it certainly requires
a great deal of sophistication and
vigilance in order to be able to
maintain a complicated online presence
and companies are trying to reach their
users as broadly as possible wherever
they might be so having an online
presence is pretty much essential to
just about every business these days
target just released the cost of that
massive data breach 148 million dollars
though they have 38 million dollars of
insurance you know we keep asking this
question can these attacks really be
stopped you know can security really get
so good that that this doesn't happen or
will the hackers just catch up every
time well I don't think that you can
ever make a system that is absolutely
unhackable from a theoretical standpoint
but what you can do is create very
practical defenses that make certain
types of attacks so expensive that the
hackers end up deciding to do something
what are those practical defenses well
this is actually one of the things that
shape security is focused on being able
to introduce barriers between different
websites in order to prevent automation
from occurring so this gang is estimated
to be about 20 people in size and yet
they've stolen over a billion
credentials the only way to do that is
through automation if you can prevent
those automated tools the vulnerability
scanners that they're using to be able
to discover the exploits in the first
place as well as all the tools that they
used to then monetize them then it
becomes much costlier for them to be
able to create a business out of these
types of putting up walls between
website like what like a quick example
well our product is called the bot wall
and what it does is it prevents any type
of automated attack from being able to
go onto your website so in this
particular case when they're trying to
use the credentials and login to other
websites to discover whether or not they
work they're actually unable to use a
script to automatically log in so if
you've got millions of credentials you
can't manually test those and try and
log into each one of them manually you
have to use some type of script using a
botnet in order to be able to reach that
scale if the automation doesn't work the
attack goes away in the business model
fail